Joining me today is the first investor
in bitcoin.com,
blockchain.com,
and several other crypto currency
websites who is also a libertarian and
individualistic and a peace advocate.
Roger Veer.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me on.
I was going to save over,
but then I did a little research and
it's actually veer.
Even though most people say this would
lead one to getting into cryptocurrency,
wouldn't it?
That's the exact reason that it's very
easy to see that.
That's why I would get into
cryptocurrencies A.
Alright.
I'm looking forward to doing this
conversation because a,
as I mentioned to you briefly before we
started for about two years or so,
I've sort of been kind of looking into
this world.
A lot of my audience,
the libertarian side of my audience of
course,
is very much into bitcoin,
so I think probably for the first half
of this we have to just do,
do one on one stuff.
Are you ready to have your,
your thinking cap on?
You Bet.
All right,
so for someone that's watching this
bitcoin,
they have no idea what that means.
They think it has some connotation to
Super Mario,
you know,
punching the question mark and getting
coins out of this thing,
which makes some sense,
I guess at some level.
What the Hell is bitcoin?
Bitcoin is thanks to the invention of
Bitcoin for the very first time in the
entire history of the world.
Any human being can now send and receive
any amount of money with any other human
being anywhere on the planet,
instantly,
basically for free.
You don't have to get permission from a
bank.
You don't have to get permission from
the corporation.
the government.
Not only do you not have to get their
permission,
it's impossible for any of those
entities to stop it,
so you can now send money from,
from here in la to to Moscow instantly
just like that for less than a penny.
And there's nothing that the Russian
government can do that there's nothing
that the Chinese government can do.
There's nothing that the American
government can do.
So if you think that it's a good thing
that people have control of their own
money and they're not susceptible to
things like we had happened in Cyprus a
few years back where the government just
came in and said,
okay,
we're going to take.
I think it was a third of it.
Everybody's money in their bank
accounts.
If you think things like that are bad,
you should love bitcoin and even if you
haven't used bitcoin yet,
it might sound complicated and
difficult.
But think of it like email.
If I sat here trying to explain to you
how email works,
it would sound really hard and confusing
and how could anybody figure out how to
do this sort of thing.
But once you've used email,
it's not hard.
It's easy.
You just type in the person's email
address and you send them a message
bitcoin's the same way.
You just paste,
copy and paste their bitcoin address and
you send them some money.
And uh,
so the best advice I can give to anybody
that's new to bit coin,
don't be afraid of it.
Go on the Internet and uh,
get a bitcoin wallet and give it a try.
It's really,
really easy to use once you've actually
used it.
Yeah.
I mentioned to you that we take
donations,
uh,
at Rubin report.com/donate
a and we take bitcoin donations.
We didn't do it for a while and we had
all these people saying,
why aren't you doing it?
You're missing a great opportunity here.
So we did it and we have about,
I think around two and a half bitcoin.
Right.
And I've seen it Kinda,
you know,
go up and you can't really watch it
everyday,
at least from where I sit.
You can't watch it everyday because you,
you'd start going crazy.
It's just like watching stocks everyday.
Um,
but what is it?
What actually is.
And so I get the ease of transfer and I
want to talk to you about why some
governments kind of embraced it more in
some really are against it and,
and all of that stuff.
But like people,
that's what people want to like what,
like gold.
We know what gold is.
It's a thing.
You can put it in your hand,
what actually is Bitcoin,
so with traditional monies that people
are used to using like the dollar or the
euro or or or traditional payment
networks like paypal or visa or
mastercard.
All of these things have one ledger that
keeps track of,
for example,
Paypal,
they have a ledger at the pay pal world
headquarters and maybe a couple of
backups.
They keep track of how many dollars you
have in your account and how many
dollars I have in my account and when I
transfer some pay pal dollars from my
account to your account,
they update their ledger,
but because they're the ones that are in
charge of that ledger and Keeping Track
of that ledger at any point,
they can reverse the transaction I made
to you.
They can take all the money out of your
account.
They can take all the money out my
The irs can go to them and say,
take the money out of both of our
accounts.
Anything can happen at any time.
That's beyond our control.
Even though we like to think of the
money that's in our pay pal account as
our money,
but in reality we have to trust paypal
to hold it because paypal has that one
ledger,
they're at the mercy of their higher
ups,
which are the government people with
bitcoin.
Instead of there being one ledger that
keeps track of who has how many bitcoins
and what account.
There's a copy of this ledger,
but it's on everybody's computer around
the world that's running a copy of the
bitcoin full nodes software and so
instead of there being,
you know,
one or two or three copies,
there's more than 100,000
copies of this ledger around the world
and those 100,000
copies of the ledger all stay in sync
with one another.
And those ledgers are in every country
around the world.
So let's say I send some money to you
via bitcoin for something that a
government doesn't like.
There's no bitcoin company that they can
call.
There's no bitcoin server.
They can unplug.
All they could do is arrest the two of
us,
but that doesn't stop the bitcoin
network as a whole.
It keeps right on going.
So the real powerful invention of
Bitcoin is this ledger that's not on any
one computer.
The ledger is distributed across the
entire planet,
so there's no single place that anybody
could go to,
to stop or modify it or unplug it or
turn it off.
And so for me,
that's what's so exciting about bitcoin
is the only way to stop it would be to
turn off the entire Internet in the
entire world and keep it turned off.
And in 2017,
I don't think that's a very likely
proposition.
And I suspect there is some bad guys.
There's got to be an evil guy somewhere
twirling his mustache going,
we can shut off the entire Internet,
right?
Uh,
maybe,
but,
uh,
hopefully not.
Then hopefully we can build even more
technologies to prevent bad people from
turning off the,
the whole world's Internet.
And we saw what happened when they tried
in a,
in Turkey,
uh,
previously they turned off the Internet.
We just within the country and people
were instantly rioting in the streets
and it led to an entire revolution in
that country.
And uh,
I suspect that would happen in a lot of
countries around the world that they
tried to turn off the internet
completely.
Okay.
So I'm with you understand that
basically the ledger,
the information,
the true information of who has what and
when they have it and all of that.
I understand that when people say we're,
we're mining for Bitcoin,
what does that actually mean?
So this ledgers,
that's all across the entire world gets
updated once on average every 10
minutes.
But it's who gets to decide who gets to
make that update.
So the way that problem was solved,
there's all these people are doing these
really complicated math problems and the
only way to find the answer to this math
problem is just to guess.
And you have to guess over and over and
over again.
So these bitcoin mining machines are
guessing millions of times a second or
even more than that.
And when they find whichever machine and
there's,
you know,
millions of these around the world,
whichever machine finds the right answer
to this math problem is then the one
that's designated to be able to make the
next update to this worldwide bitcoin
ledgers than all these different nodes
around the world make their update and
boom,
the transactions that the,
the networks that the next state and
then all the computer start trying to
guess again.
But the benefit of finding the right
answer to this solution is at the moment
you get 12 and a half bitcoins.
If your computer is the one that finds
the right solution and 12 and a half
bitcoins at the moment is worthwhile.
Like 80,
$80,000
or so.
Oh,
I should mention by the way that we're
taping this probably about two weeks
before it's going to air.
So anything we say related to the
specific numbers,
I don't want people to take out of
context.
They got beer,
doesn't know what he's talking about
because it was too bright for,
you know.
Okay.
And,
and almost certainly by the time this
airs,
it'll be something that I said
basically,
even if we were doing this live right
now,
things would be changing on the fly.
I'd have to check live on the,
on the phone to see what the current
prices to figure it out.
And,
and Bitcoin is volatile.
But from my point of view,
I want to be exposed to as much of that
volatility as I possibly can because
bitcoin allows you to send and receive
any amount of money with anyone anywhere
in the world basically for free.
And there's nothing anybody could do to
stop it.
And there's a limited supply of bitcoin.
They will never,
ever,
ever be more than 21 million bitcoin.
So if you stop.
So how does that work exactly?
Because I've heard that.
So they'll never be more than 21 yet.
We've got all these computers that are
constantly working to get the next
solution to the mathematical equation.
So how is there a finite number of.
So if one of these,
if one of these computers decided to
give itself more than the 12 and a half
bitcoins that are supposed to be
allocated,
all the other computers will reject that
and say,
no,
that's not part of the rules of the game
that,
that in our software code.
So any computer that deviates from that,
their transactions in whatever they're
trying to do just gets rejected and
ignored by the rest of the network.
So right from day one it was programmed
into the software code that there
wouldn't be more than 21 million
bitcoins,
but those are released over time.
So a half of the remaining bitcoins are
released every four years.
So in the first four years of Bitcoins,
Bitcoin,
10 and a half million coins were
released in the next four years,
half of that,
in the next four years,
half of that.
And,
uh,
it drops by half every four years.
So,
so what year will they all officially we
have more than 100 years until the last
of the bitcoins are released out into
the public.
So,
uh,
that's,
it's not a pressing problem at the
moment,
but what would even,
I mean we don't have to go too far down
that since it's 100 years from now,
but what would happen when we hit,
when we hit the point that they're all
out there,
does that somehow drastically changed
the way the game is played?
Well,
the idea is that by that point,
people that are doing bitcoin
transactions,
even if they're paying a fraction of a
penny per bitcoin transaction of people
are doing billions of transactions per
day,
those fees have a fraction of a penny
per transaction will incentivize the
miners to continue mining.
And we have 100 and something years to,
to find out to figure that out.
Yeah,
I suspect there will be some other
issues.
So there's more pressing problems than,
than that one at the moments here.
Right.
Okay.
So how,
so it sounds to me that it's,
it's incredibly secure.
Right.
Can you just talk a little bit more
about the general security?
Yeah.
So the,
the bitcoin network,
all these computers around the world
that are doing mining a more accurate
description of what they're doing is
actually they're securing the bitcoin
network.
So the more computers that are mining
the more secure the bitcoin network is
and the bitcoin network is somewhere on
the order of several thousand times more
powerful now than the world's top 500
supercomputers combined.
So it's absolutely an incredible feat of
engineering.
Wait.
So how do you get that kind of computing
power?
Like are there just,
I assume there's farms of servers just
like it's just someone that invested in
a farm,
right?
I mean is that well how it works.
And initially it was just people at home
in their bedroom because you know,
you,
if you found a block you would get a
dollar.
And so it wasn't that excited.
But now today when you find a block on
the blockchain,
you get,
you know,
80,000
plus dollars.
So now it's big,
big business.
So people have big,
giant warehouses filled with tens of
millions of dollars of this mining
equipment using,
you know,
tens of megawatts of power per,
per location,
and it's a big,
big business at this point and you can
still do it at home.
One of the most important factors though
is the cost of electricity.
So the cheaper your electricity is,
the more profitable your bitcoin mining
can be.
So I assume there's some bitcoin people
that probably want to go into solar and
moved to Nevada or something.
Yup.
And then there's people going around
looking at buying power plants and
buying hydroelectric dams,
all sorts of stuff.
It's really become a worldwide major
industry at this point.
Yeah.
I mentioned to you the DNA.
We're going to have to do some
definitions here.
So blockchain,
what is blockchain?
Blockchain is just a fancy name for this
worldwide ledger that's kept on
everybody's computer that's running this
copy of the software and the ledger
stays in sync with every other copies.
So that's,
uh,
that's basically what a blockchain is.
And the reason it's called a blockchain
is that ledger.
It's not updated all the time.
It's updated and steps and each step or
update is a block of new information
that's attached and they're all chained
together mathematically,
so they're all in order,
so if a new block gets added to the end
of the blockchain on average once every
10 minutes and now the blockchain is,
I don't know,
coming up on half a million blocks long
and it's been going on for,
I don't know,
eight,
nine years now,
something like that.
What are most people use actually using
bitcoin for right now?
Like are they using it mostly just to
transfer money from person to person or.
I noticed actually just two days I
bought something on overstock.com
and it was the first time that I ever
saw on an ecommerce site that I could
have paid in bitcoin.
I had actually never seen that before,
but what?
What are most people using bitcoin for
a.
I think it depends on.
It's kind of like asking what do most
people use money for?
An imperative.
In my book,
Bitcoin is money,
so people use money in different ways.
Some people save with it,
some people spend it,
some people gamble on the Internet with
it,
some people buy drugs with it,
some people do whatever it is they want
with it,
but in my point of view,
each each person owns their own money
and they should be free to do whatever
they want with it.
So long as they're not initiating force
or fraud against other people.
And I'm curious,
do you know what any of the trends are
like are people really at the moment
just getting into bitcoin so they can
save it,
hoping that,
you know,
treating it more as a stock than an than
actual cash or they.
All right.
Then we can also talk about a little bit
about the split with bitcoin cash do.
That's probably a good segue to that,
but do you have any sense of what the
actual habits are?
Yeah,
so I think that's a great segue into
that.
So when I first got involved in Bitcoin,
I was the first person in the entire
world to start investing in bitcoin
startups.
So my first step where,
let's pause there for a second.
This is 2011,
right?
Right.
What are our 2011 bitcoins are less than
a dollar each.
Okay.
And what possessed you to get involved?
Like what did you see that you were
like,
all right,
this is going to be something.
So,
um,
I grew up in silicon valley than playing
with computers since I was little kid
love computers all the time.
Um,
and my hobby was studying economics and
uh,
just kind of by chance,
I came across one economics book in
junior high when my mother told me I
couldn't play anymore Nintendo.
I had to go and do something else.
I picked up a book off the bookshelf and
just by luck it was a book called
socialism by loaded.
Bobby says,
and some people may know who that is and
what that book is and most people I
expect won't.
And when I picked up that book,
I thought it was a pro socialism book
and I didn't really even know what
socialism was,
but I kind of knew that Americans were
supposed to be opposed to socialism.
But I thought,
you know,
I should have an open mind.
I should at least hear what the other
side of the,
you know,
this point of view has to say,
and it turned out that,
I think it was the Wall Street Journal
referred to Mommy says book socialism is
loaded,
is devastating critique of socialism.
And in this book he kind of points out
that prices are incredibly important and
without the pricing mechanism,
you don't know what raw resources should
be used to produce what consumer goods.
So this,
you know,
my,
my glass of water here is made of glass
that I don't know.
I don't even know how they make the
glass,
but I guess some sand and they melt it
down or something like that.
But without the price that we got it
from target for the record.
So we spare no expense around here.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
And with the prices that go into the
sand and then the factory and this and
that,
they know that maybe they should make
glasses out of sand rather than glasses
out of gold or glasses out of copper or
take your pick.
And so all the prices all over the world
allocate all of these resources and all
of these companies and all these
factories and people and individuals all
the way to the time when you get to
target and you look at the different
glasses there and you think this one's
glass,
this one's plastic,
this one suits my need better than this
one and this one cost this much,
and it allocates the resources of the
entire world.
Without a pricing mechanism,
you have no idea what raw resources
should be used to create what consumer
goods and reading this book,
it was like,
wow.
Anytime the government gets involved in
any area of the economy,
they're causing a misallocation of
resources and resources are being
diverted from their most economically
efficient use to something that's less
economically efficient and saying
something's less economically efficient
is just a fancier way of saying you're
making the world a poorer place than it
otherwise would have been.
And so I found these ideas incredibly
interesting and it,
it I,
it gave me a better understanding of the
world.
And so I read one economics book after
another,
after another after another,
and so I,
I got to read these theories about the
origin of money and what the origin of
money is and the idea of the origin of
money is that it starts out as a
commodity,
but not just any commodity.
It has to be commodity that's easily
recognizable,
easily divisible,
easily transportable.
You can store it easily for a long time
and it won't go moldy or disappeared.
It has to have these certain
characteristics that make something as
money.
And I read about these theories in the
books and I was pretty convinced by the
theories,
and not to go down a whole nother
tangent,
but I actually did some time in federal
prison in the US as well.
And when I was in federal,
I've got it noted right there.
Okay.
While I was in federal prison,
I got to see firsthand in this micro
prison economy that sure enough,
the theories in the books that I'd read
about the origin of money were true in
practice.
So I got to see within the prison that
sure enough people are using commodities
as money.
So in prison people use tobacco and
postage stamps and top ramen soups as
money because all of those things are
easily storable,
easily transportable,
easily divisible,
easily recognizable.
Uh,
and of course a limited supply is
important as well.
And so I got to see firsthand before my
eyes that the theories that I had read
about in the books are actually true in
practice.
And then bitcoin came along and I saw
bitcoin and I knew from the theories and
the books and from the practical
experience and the empirical evidence I
had from the prison economy,
I knew people were going to start using
it as money and because the supply of
Bitcoin was limited and I knew people
were going to start using it as money,
that meant the price of bitcoin in terms
of dollars would have to go up.
So my first step was to buy a bunch of
bitcoin and my next step was to start
building that.
Sorry to interrupt.
But at that early stage,
when you say,
all right,
I'm going to buy Bitcoin,
who you actually even buying it from
then?
So this was a,
I think February of 2011.
And so there wasn't really an easy way
to buy bitcoin at that point.
There was no,
there was no coinbase,
there was a,
there wasn't much of anything other than
this one company called Mt.
Gox and it wasn't really much of a
company at that point.
So I sent my first wire to a person's
personal bank account,
a guy named Jed mccaleb to his personal
bank account in New York.
And I got my first big ones in there.
And then in parallel I was trying to buy
bitcoins from another guy off the
Internet for anybody who's been around
in Bitcoin for a while,
they may have seen the physical
[inaudible] sassiest bitcoins.
So the guy behind that was also nice
enough to send me some bitcoins.
And so one time there was actually a
physical there.
There still are,
but they're more of a collector's item
at this point.
And basically it's a physical coin with
a Hologram.
And when you peel a hologram off,
you can see that it's been tampered with
and underneath the Hologram is the magic
number that's required to actually spend
the bitcoins.
Um,
do they start?
So they still do make those or maybe
someone somewhere still making them.
But it was the reason just because at
the beginning people needed some sort of
physical representation just to kind of
understand.
I think the main reason is it made it
easier for people to get a hold of
bitcoin.
So I'm one of the main things that I did
that really help spread a bitcoin
adoption in the early days,
in 2012,
I think it was when bitcoins were like
three bucks each.
I started selling these physical
bitcoins and I accepted credit cards and
pay pal and I would ship them via Fedex
and we had proof of delivery.
So it made it hard for people to do
credit card charge backs or that sort of
thing.
And we saw thousands and thousands of
these physical bitcoins to people all
over the world that way.
And it was an easy way for people to get
their first bitcoin because then they
could peel off the sticker and redeemed
them onto their computer or do whatever
they wanted with them from there.
And uh,
today they're,
they're quite the collector's items
because there's not too many left of
those early [inaudible] CSF physical
bitcoins.
Right.
So,
okay.
So you,
you make this initial investment in
2011,
2012.
When did you start to realize that this
really was becoming something?
And as we speak right now,
it's Bitcoin is basically at its highest
value of all,
all time in effect.
Yeah.
I,
I knew from,
from day one,
once I put together the pieces in my
mind and I understood that bitcoin could
be shut down or stopped or controlled in
any way and that there's a limited
supply.
I was so excited about this,
that,
uh,
I heard about it.
And as I was eating breakfast at around
10:00
AM with the full intent of going into my
office that day didn't make it.
I stayed home and read about bitcoin all
day.
I stayed up all night the next day until
around 4:00
PM the next day and I got too tired and
I fell asleep for only about an hour and
then woke up again and read all about
bitcoin and I went on sleeping maybe an
hour and a half per night for about a
whole week until I got so sick from lack
of sleep.
I had to call my friends,
help me.
I'm so sick and he came and picked me up
and drove me to the hospital and they
gave me some sort of a sedative or
something and I.
I passed out asleep for maybe 12 or 16
hours,
but then woke up again and it was all
bitcoin and here we are about seven
years later and it's been all bitcoin
all day,
every day for seven years now because
this is literally.
It's one of the most important
inventions in the entire history of
humankind.
Right up there on par with the
importance of the invention of the wheel
or the electricity or the transistor.
That's how big of a deal the invention
of bitcoin is.
So I want to get into that and how it
can sort of,
why you really believe this can change
the way we deal with borders and
societies and nations and wars and all
of this a bit.
But let's just circle back quickly to
the.
The split.
This bitcoin cash,
bitcoin split.
Yep.
So when I first got excited about
Bitcoin,
you could send and receive any amount of
bitcoin with anyone anywhere in the
world and it was free most of the time,
the times it wasn't for you.
Pay a fraction of a penny and that led
bitcoin from being worth almost nothing
to this worldwide phenomenon that it is
today,
but much more recently within the last
year to a bunch of people that don't
have any background in economics or or
in business seem to think that people
will use bitcoin solely as a store of
value even if it costs tens or hundreds
or thousands of dollars to send bitcoin
from one person to another.
And so they've intentionally undermine
bitcoin's usefulness in commerce.
So bitcoin on August first split into
two versions of Bitcoin,
there's now a bitcoin segwit and bitcoin
cash.
The bitcoin cash version of bitcoin
still has fees are less than a penny you
can send and receive them with anyone
anywhere in the world,
just like that.
Bitcoin segwit.
Now the average fee is about $10 a.
I did a bitcoin transaction on the way
here.
Uh,
in fact I was sin sending my bitcoin
segwit bitcoins to a bitcoin exchange to
buy more bitcoin cash.
Bitcoin's the fee for me to send those
bitcoins for my computer to the bitcoin
exchange with $100.
And so if you ask yourself,
you have two versions of bitcoin and one
is slow,
expensive and unreliable bitcoin segwit,
and you have another version of bitcoin
that's super fast,
reliable and cheap.
It's not the type to say,
and that's bitcoin cash,
it's not a tough decision as to which
one people are going to start using it
in commerce.
But these,
right?
So I might,
I might be a little confused here.
So when I'm telling you that I have two
and a half Bitcoin,
I,
when you say bitcoin and Segwit,
that's the original,
the original,
so to speak.
Right?
So that's debatable as well.
Um,
so it,
depending on when you received those two
and a half bitcoins,
that was probably from a bunch of people
over time,
however many bitcoins you had on August,
first of this year,
you now have that many bitcoin cash as
well.
So let's say you had two bitcoins
exactly on August.
First,
you now have two bitcoins and into
bitcoin cash.
Um,
although I believe you said that you
were holding your bitcoins on coinbase.
I did.
And as we were talking about before,
the show base is a fantastic company,
but it's not a bitcoin wallet.
It's a bit coin bank and they're holding
the bitcoins on your behalf and now
they're holding the bitcoin cash on your
behalf.
And so you're going to have to wait for
them to get around to giving you access
to their bitcoin cash,
which I think they will.
But if you were using a bit coin wallet
in which you're holding the bitcoins
yourself on your own device,
you would have access to your bitcoin
cash right there from day one.
So what do you mean?
I don't have access to it?
If I was to right now,
log in and I got to do all that stuff on
my phone and all of the password
craziness and all that,
I'm very happy that you have to do all
those things obviously.
What do you mean I don't have access to
it?
You only have access to the bitcoin
segwit version of bitcoin on coinbase
today.
They've promised to give everybody
access to their bitcoin cash at some
point and hopefully they'll do that
sooner rather than later.
But August first was a couple of months
ago now and they still haven't gotten
around to doing it and I'm confident
that they will,
but it's nice to have access to your
money now and not have to wait around
for somebody else to do it.
And that's why it's very important.
And I always tell people,
use a bitcoin wallet,
not a Bitcoin Bank.
So why wouldn't everyone want bitcoin
cash though?
Unless I'm missing something.
I think everyone is going to want
bitcoin cash.
There's book.
So then what was the logic?
Yeah.
What's the reason everyone's not using
it yet is that this bitcoin Seibert
version of bitcoin managed to bring
along all of the existing infrastructure
in bitcoin that's been around for nine
years now,
eight years now.
Bitcoin cash has only been around a
couple of months since August first,
and the fact that bitcoin cash is now
supported on the bitcoin.com
wallet,
it's supported in the blockchain dot
Info Wallet,
a coin base as public as they said,
they're going to support it.
Uh,
it's supported in the bitpay wallet.
It's getting more and more support from
wallets and merchant processors and
exchanges.
Uh,
I think it's a matter of time when
people are faced between a fast,
cheap and reliable version of bitcoin
and it's super slow and expensive and
unreliable version of bitcoin.
There's,
what's the argument from the slow
people,
the people that don't agree with you on
this?
What's the actual argument?
If we're really just talking about slow
speeds and a clunkier process,
obviously that doesn't sound good.
So to have fast,
cheap,
reliable transactions on Bitcoin,
it requires a more expensive computer to
run a full node,
but the vast,
vast,
vast majority of bitcoin users aren't
running a full note anyhow.
You've probably never run a full node in
your entire life and nobody,
you know,
none of these coin based users are
running a full node.
Coinbase runs a number of full notes to
support your bitcoin transactions.
So if you have
the bitcoin cash version will require
bigger blocks which require a more
powerful CPU and more storage space.
So right now today you can run a bitcoin
full node for the Bitcoin segwit
version,
literally on a $25 raspberry Pi.
These people are ready to take.
What is that about?
A Raspberry Pi is a $25 computer and
that's the name of the computer.
So there's a cup.
Yeah,
there's,
there's an actual competitor.
We are another thing on pies now.
But wait,
there's a computer called the raspberry
Pi I to the number of acts.
So you see there's a lot of terms here.
We're running this thing on cakes.
Okay.
So you can run the Bitcoin segwit
version of Bitcoin on a $25 computer.
Bitcoin cash today can still run under
$25 computer,
but in the future as bitcoin cash
becomes more popular,
maybe it'll take $100 computer or even a
500 or even a thousand or a couple
thousand dollar computer at some at some
point.
But that's okay.
Most people aren't running full nodes
anyhow and if you're,
if you caught it cost five or 10 or $100
to use bitcoin segwit and it cost a
penny to use bitcoin cash.
It's clear.
So you were,
you've been accepting donations on your
website.
I think you got most of those donations
before the price of bitcoin transaction
skyrocketed.
And the reason the price of Bitcoin
segwit transactions skyrocket is there's
one megabyte worth of transactions that
can happen each 10 minute period that
can hold about 2000 bitcoin transactions
in the early days,
maybe 10 people were using bitcoin every
10 minutes.
So you could do it for free and your
transaction will be included.
Now that bitcoin is this worldwide
phenomenon,
more than 2000 people are trying to use
bitcoin every 10 minutes,
but you want your transaction to be
included in the blockchain.
So if more than 2000 people are trying
to use every 10 minutes,
they have to bid against each other and
the top bidders are the ones that are
included in the next block on the
blockchain.
So now the fees are about $10 per per
transaction because anybody that pays $9
has been outbid by the people that are
paying $10.
So bitcoin cash a solution to that as
well.
Just make the blocks bigger than one
megabyte.
It's 2017.
Eight terabyte hard drive is about 100
bucks at the moment,
didn't they're only going to get cheaper
year after year.
So you're feeling basically is that the
technology will always sort of the
computing power that we need for this
will always sort of stay in front of the
problems,
right?
So just because it keeps getting faster
and there's this great thing called
Moore's law,
which is exactly that.
That computing power doubles about every
18 months and so if a eight terabyte
hard drive today is $100 in a year and a
half from now,
it's going to be about $50 and a year
half after that,
you know,
$25.
And before you know what their garbage
in the landfill and people laugh at a
eight terabyte hard drive the same way
we'd laugh.
I bet eight megabyte hard drive today,
but I remember eight megabyte hard
drives and I remember when they were
several hundred dollars and I'm not that
old of a guy in the same as going to
continue to happen with computers.
Before we know it.
You mentioned the window before.
I remember when the first,
I think it was four megabyte game came
out on Sega Genesis and it's big deal
and they were going.
People were going completely bananas
about it.
That is many lifetimes ago.
Uh,
just real quick,
let's circle back to this,
to this Wallet Verse Bank Thing Because
I think,
uh,
maybe maybe I could be a little clearer
on what you're saying.
So coinbase as a bank is really just
holding my bitcoin.
If they were,
if I had this in a wallet,
then that's actually part of the actual
blockchain right here.
If you haven't in a bitcoin wallet,
you're interfacing directly with the
actual bitcoin network.
Whereas when you use a bitcoin bank like
coinbase,
you're interfacing with coinbase and
you're saying,
please broadcast my transaction to the
bitcoin network and most of the time
they do,
but like your bitcoin cash at the
moment,
you don't have access to it and I would
actually recommend that on your website
you should put a bitcoin cash address up
there because right now people want to
tip you in.
Bitcoin is going to cost them five or
$10 in network fee.
So if they wanted to give you a dollar
in Bitcoin,
they're going to have to pay six or $11
to do that.
And I don't think too many people are
going to do that.
These don't seem like the type of people
that would make sense to you.
Whereas if they want it to tip you in
bitcoin cash,
if a dollar they'll have to send a
dollar and a penny and that's very
tolerable to people and I'm more than
happy after we record,
I can show you this bitcoin cash.
Well,
I'm going to say,
yeah,
I've got my own farm out their servers
and we're going to fiddle around with.
So then why would someone use a bank
then?
I think they just didn't understand the
different.
It's just like yourself.
I think you didn't realize the
difference between coinbase and a real
big coin wallet until now.
Fascinating.
All right,
well I think we did a pretty decent job
there of the little stuff.
Do you feel like we basically got the
one.
Am I missing something on the one one
for anybody that feels like they're
missing anything on the [inaudible],
go go to bitcoin dot Khan.
I'm a little bit biased because that's
my website,
but it's a fantastic resource.
Get a bitcoin wallet and start using
it.
It's like email.
If you'd never actually used email and
you only heard people discuss the show,
it would seem hard,
but once you've used it,
it's easy.
It's the same with bitcoin.
So go and actually use it and,
and use it with bitcoin cash because it
won't cost you $5 each time you use it.
It'll cost you less than a penny each
time you make a transaction.
All right,
so the part of this,
so shifting from all that,
the part of this that I thought was
really interesting beyond just the
financial discussion and just sort of
the way the future of commerce is going
to work and all that is you really
believe that bitcoin can change the way
governments act,
the way,
the way we as individuals respond to
and,
and talk to our governments and all of
that.
Uh,
so I'm giving you a sort of a broad
question there,
but uh,
tell me about that.
I hear people asking me all the time or
aren't is going to regulate bitcoin and
what about government regulation and
Bitcoin?
But I think they're asking the wrong
question.
The real,
the real end game here is isn't that
governments are going to regulate
bitcoin.
Bitcoin is going to regulate
governments.
Bitcoin is going to limit the power that
every government on the planet has to
control people.
A look at what happened a few years ago
in Cyprus where every single person
there had,
you know,
a big percentage of their bank account
just completely wiped out.
Bitcoin gives the ability to people to
opt out of that sort of system in the
United States here,
you know,
the government can print as much money
at any time for any reason and you
better believe that they're doing that
all the time if you're using bitcoin.
That sort of thing can happen.
And one of these really interesting
ideas that had never occurred to me when
I was,
you know,
going on my binge ever,
any economics books as a kid was a by
Milton Friedman and he pointed out the
idea of bracket creep and the government
inflates the currency every single year.
So maybe having,
you know,
two or three percent inflation and you
know,
you're one year to the next.
That's not that big of a deal,
but compounding year after year after
year,
before you know it,
$100,000
isn't intended,
or 20 years from now,
it's not gonna be that big of an income,
right?
But the government tax brackets are
likely to stay about the same.
So maybe $50,000
income today is the equivalent of
$100,000.
Your income after however many years it
takes to compound to that.
So instead of being in a,
you know,
25 percent tax bracket,
you're going to be in a 45 percent tax
bracket even though you're not actually
earning any more money each year.
Bitcoin is the exact opposite of that.
There's no central authority that can
make more bitcoins out of thin air
unlike the US dollar.
So that's a really powerful way of
people to opt out of this government
inflation racket that they had that they
used to bump everybody into higher tax
brackets year after year.
Right?
So it's sort of,
it's kind of hard to picture what this
would actually look like in the future.
But if you,
if everything you're predicting and
would like to happen,
happened,
even effect as the years go by,
people will obviously be buying more
bitcoin using the US dollar in whatever
country they're in,
whatever their currencies,
they're gonna use that less and that
that vary by just doing that.
The governments will in effect have less
control over the people because all of
your,
all of your interactions,
all of your exchanges will have nothing
to do with the government.
Can Sam grinning from ear to ear as
someone who's this white is in Bitcoin,
is illegal in China?
Or are they just changed something or
wasn't there something just in the last
couple of weeks?
They've changed a lot of things in,
in China at the moment,
but at the end of the day it doesn't
matter if you have access to the
Internet,
you can use bitcoin and this is really,
really,
really exciting.
And I,
I guess it's worth pointing out too,
like I wasn't born a libertarian.
I,
I wasn't even.
I didn't really have any political views
at all.
It was the more economics I studied,
the more of a libertarian I became and
then it was kind of really depressing
because I looked around the world and
governments are manipulating the economy
and all these ways that are preventing
or slowing down the entire world's rate
of economic growth and economic growth
of,
you know,
two or three or four percent per year
from one year to the next.
That's not that big of a deal,
but compounded year after year after
year,
it really makes a huge,
huge difference.
And so even if the government is just
slowing down the rate of economic growth
by just one percent and I think it's
substantially more than that compound,
that times 100 or a couple of hundred
years,
we'd all have flying cars and space
stations by now and be living forever
because of little nano technology.
Robots that can go on our body and fix
everything that's wrong with us and who
doesn't want that sort of thing.
And if you don't want it,
don't participate.
You're not forced to participate.
And that's what we're talking about,
were slowing down the rate of progress
of all of humankind.
And bitcoin is this incredibly powerful
tool to help speed up that rate of
progress.
Man,
there's so many different ways I could
go with that.
Uh,
so the dystopian future part of this
that I guess I would fear is that if,
if the government loses control of the
monetary system,
all the governments whose control and
the only way they can stop us now is to
go after the Internet.
Wouldn't it stand to reason that
governments would start going after the
internet?
They're like literally the Internet
itself,
like actually try to disconnect the
internet,
maybe whatever that.
But lots of governments are dependent on
the Internet as well.
But there's also lots of smart people
that are building these mesh networks in
which it's not,
it's not dependent on the same sort of
centralized infrastructure that allowed
the Internet is today.
And those technologies are only going to
get more and more powerful and cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper thanks to
Moore's law.
And before we know it will all be able
to connect with everybody else.
And we won't be dependent on,
you know,
these big esps and how do they go about
doing that,
like a mesh network like that.
So basically in effect,
getting us off Google and verizon and
whatever else,
right?
Like that,
those won't be the only pathways.
How do these guys get out of that
system?
Um,
well I think we're of a similar age and
I'm sure both of us remember before
there were smartphones and before there
were iphones and before there was Siri
and Google and all these things.
And,
and now you have the entire database of
human knowledge right in your hand.
And if you buy a used iphone,
you can get it for about a hundred bucks
and another couple of years that's going
to buy a cheap android phone for 20
bucks right now.
Like,
that's incredible.
So the hardware to do this is going to
get cheaper and cheaper.
The technology is going to become more
and more accessible.
Uh,
it's gonna be cheaper and cheaper for
anybody to put satellites up in space
and maybe government,
you're going to try and stop this and
do,
do bad things to do that.
But if they start trying to shut down
the world's Internet to prevent people
from using their own money,
that's just a fantastic example that the
government people are the bad people and
they're not our friends and they're not
here to help us.
Anybody that's here trying to say,
hey,
we're going to turn off the Internet if
you use money without our permission.
Those are bad people.
We shouldn't support them.
We shouldn't want anything to do with
them.
And that's just more proof that we do
need bitcoin to opt out of there.
They're violent curse of system to
control us all.
We shouldn't be their tax cattle,
livestock.
It's a great sell for libertarianism in
general.
Like if mean this is what I am always,
you know,
selling the ideas of freedom.
It's like if you think people,
everyone complains,
the government's horrible all the time.
You have half the people want to give
them more money and give them more
control.
And it's like,
no,
do the opposite.
Yeah,
you don't starve them,
but let's try it.
Let's try it that way.
So I think I'm follow the logic here.
So when you talk about how,
why this would basically stop wars to do
you mean because of economic reasons or
because basically we wouldn't be giving
the economic reasons,
meaning countries wouldn't have an
economic incentive to fight,
but also that the people wouldn't be
giving them enough money to fight in the
first place.
Is that.
So there's a couple of reasons.
And uh,
since we have quite a big audience,
I've never talked about one of them
publicly,
a really up until now,
what will they think about that one too?
All right,
let's throw one of,
one of the easy,
simple reasons is that lots of
governments fund their wars,
the inflation.
They just print money and they use that
money to buy guns and bombs and tanks
and they use it to murder people all
over the world.
And a war is just a euphemism for
murder.
Uh,
you're,
you're killing.
Sometimes some bad people get killed,
but for the most part,
innocent civilians are getting killed
all over the world and let's say
somebody came in here and stole my
wallet,
ran off down the street.
If I started chasing them down the
street and shooting guns and I,
I shot a dozen innocent people that
didn't steal my wallet.
I said,
oh,
it's okay,
because I was trying to get the bad guy
who stole my wallet.
I would go to jail for being a murder,
for killing all those incident people.
So let's say let's take for granted.
Let's say Saddam Hussein was a really
bad guy who deserved to be killed.
They murdered more than half a million
Iraqi children to do it.
Right?
That's murder.
You're killing kids,
right?
It doesn't matter how bad of a Guy
Saddam Hussein is.
You don't go and kill a bunch of kids to
get them,
and that's exactly what the United
States government did,
and if any individual did that trying to
catch a common thief,
you would go to jail for it.
But for whatever reason,
people just have amnesia or a closed
eyes when when governments do the exact
same thing,
if you're murdering innocent people,
you're a murderer and that's what
governments do and they do it primarily
through printing money and use that to
pay people to go and drop these bombs
and guns and tanks and bitcoin takes
that power away from them because if the
the end game is to have bitcoin replaced
the dollar of place to your place placed
in and when I'm saying Bitcoin to Dan,
referring to bitcoin cash to be clear,
okay,
but replace all those things and that
takes away government's ability to
inflate the currency,
to pay for all these things and people
maybe sometimes they worry.
Well,
what about schools and roads and bridges
and hospitals?
Well guess what?
People love schools.
They love hospitals.
They love roads and bridges.
Things that people like people will be
more than willing to pay for
voluntarily.
I'm not interested in paying to drop
bombs on people in countries.
I've never been to an I'm probably never
going to go to.
And I think 99 percent of the people out
there in the world also are interested
in doing that.
And for the one percent that are
interested in doing it,
do that with your money.
Don't force me to participate.
Right.
The other really,
really interesting way that I've never
ever spoken about publicly up until now.
But I think bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
are a big enough part of our society at
this point where I'm not really worried
about the attacks from governments on
them.
And initially that was my strategy from
day one.
I wanted to spread bitcoin to as many
people around the world as quickly as I
possibly could.
They would become too big and too wide
spread to be shut down.
So if people are using bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies to buy their groceries
and their diapers and things like that,
how can government shut it down?
But here's an interesting way,
but do you think we've hit that
threshold yet?
But we're,
we're,
we're getting,
we're getting pretty darn close to that.
And at this point,
uh,
you know,
there's,
I don't know,
a hundred something,
200 something governments around the
world.
If one government wants to shut it down,
that probably makes other governments
like it even more.
I would guess maybe there's a bit of
that at this moment.
Uh,
China has been cracking down a bit,
quite a bit.
I would guess trump in the u.
s government maybe like bit coin a
little bit more now that China doesn't
like it,
which we could use a little bit of that
leverage with China,
right?
Because how much do we owe them an
actual dollar?
Sure.
Maybe we can pay them back in bitcoin
for pennies on the dollar in the future
once the RMB goes to nothing because
everybody's using cryptocurrencies.
But another really,
really interesting thing.
So let's go back in time.
And a bad guy that everybody agrees
upon,
you know,
Adolf Hitler.
I think pretty much.
I thought I could do one show without a
Hitler reference while I'm playing it
safe in my example here as well.
So let's say,
and I'm sure you can find people out
there that don't think he was a bad guy,
but the vast majority of society does
think he was a bad guy.
So Adolf Hitler started doing bad things
with money stolen from people in the
form of taxes and what did the rest of
the world do?
They started stealing money from other
people in the form of taxes,
had kidnapping and slavery in the form
of a draft.
Right?
And like lots of people went
voluntarily,
but I'm sure lots of people went in
voluntarily and we should be clear with
our language,
right?
The draft is the moral equivalent of
kidnapping and slavery.
There are literally kidnapping people
and enslaving them and sending them off
to some far off land to fight against
their will.
And if they don't do that,
they go to jail and half the time when
they go off to the far off land,
they get killed as well.
So the draft is the moral equivalent of
kidnapping,
slavery.
So Adolf Hitler is a bad guy.
Everybody agrees with that almost
everyone.
But then the rest of the governments
around the world start going and doing
all this crazy bad stuff.
Well,
what would happen if we had this online
anonymous digital cash in which people
could pool their resources and set up a
betting pool and anybody that correctly
predict the right day that Adolf Hitler
dries,
I can anonymously collect this,
you know,
millions of dollars in,
in anonymous digital cash that people
all chipped in a buck here and a buck
there and 10 bucks a year.
I bet you could have raised a lot of
money for someone to correctly predict
the right day that Adolf Hitler dies.
I mean,
this is,
I said dystopian before.
Now you're,
you're going real dystopia.
Dystopia,
or is this a utopia?
Right?
Imagine if people could have raised 10
million bucks voluntarily for around the
world and Adolf Hitler can't round up
and send them off to the concentration
camps anymore.
Is that a dystopia or a utopia?
Well,
it's a huge.
Right,
so it's a utopia in this explanation.
There's a piece of me and I love all
these,
these Topian movies,
which is why I can go down this road and
all kinds of different ways.
There's a piece that's sort of like,
wow,
you could really end up creating some
insane vigilante system where it's not
just Hitler that's going to be taken
out,
but any,
you know,
anybody that gets smeared by the media
or whatever,
and then this is constantly happening to
people that actually don't deserve it.
So that would be the dystopian part.
But in this part,
so I've been thinking about this for
more than a decade since before bitcoin.
And uh,
yeah,
it's scary,
you know,
we don't want to see know Justin Bieber
or people like that we'll be having bad
things happen to happen to them.
But on the net,
and you know,
if you look in the last century,
governments murdered more than a hundred
million people around the world and
that's all a lot of people.
So in effect you think it would cause
governments to police themselves
basically to do good things because they
would,
if there's a,
basically a ransom on them or.
Right.
Like that's,
that's really the idea here.
It it might do that or it might just
make it too dangerous for governments in
the traditional form that we have today
where they go around and boss people
around and threatened to send them to
jail.
If they don't obey,
maybe it'll make that sort of thing.
Not Possible,
and as a voluntary yes to.
I think all human interaction should be
on a voluntary basis.
A starbucks asks me to buy their coffee.
They don't tell me to buy their coffee.
If I.
If I decided I don't want to buy
starbucks coffee,
nothing bad happens to me at all,
but if I decide I don't want to pay for
Obama care,
if I was a US citizen living in the
United States,
I would go to jail for not doing it.
If I think health insurance to obamacare
is a good idea,
I'll pay for it myself.
I don't need to be forced at the point
of a gun or with the threat of being
sent to jail to,
to participate in that sort of thing and
that's what governments are.
The very definition of government is a
monopoly on the use of force and they're
forcing people to do things against
their will and if you think forcing
peaceful people to do things against
their will is a bad thing.
You should be opposed to the state and I
don't know what the end effect of the
invention of cryptocurrencies will be on
governments,
but I'm sure it will vastly,
vastly,
vastly limit their power and that's a
great thing for all of humankind.
It liberates the individual and it
speeds up the rate of economic growth
for the world.
Like maybe there's some scary things
that'll happen,
but the benefits far,
far,
far outweigh the drawbacks.
I suspect that some people are probably
watching this going,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
This guy is just trying to talk a bit
bitcoin because he probably owns a lot
of bitcoin and he'll talk it up,
talk it up,
get it going,
and then when he feels it's hit its peak
or when he wants to cash out cash out
and then that's that.
So there is some truth.
I own a lot of bitcoin and bitcoin cash
becomes really successful over the
world.
All make a lot of money.
I've already made a lot of money,
but I've already donated millions to,
to charity.
I donated several hundred thousand
dollars to help Ross Ulbricht,
um,
get his appeal going and hopefully get
out of prison for those that don't know,
Ross Ulbricht is the person that was,
uh,
convicted of creating the Silk Road,
which was the first online anonymous
marketplace in which people could buy
and sell anything that sole purpose
wasn't to harm other people.
And uh,
that guy for creating a website now has
a double life sentence,
plus 40 years.
He didn't kill a single person.
He built a website and now the
government sent them to jail for two
life sentences plus 40 years.
So his mom would make a fantastic guest
on your show in the future.
She's an incredibly wonderful woman.
And can you imagine,
you know,
if you have kids,
imagine your son got sent to jail and
he's gonna die in prison for having
built a website that allows people to
buy and sell things.
Mainly Pot,
is that what it was?
What I was going to say?
What would it be?
Mainly drugs is what people were using
it for and if you think about it,
what are drugs?
Drugs are things that make people feel
happy and there's a bunch of alcohol on
the shelf behind me.
Why is that drug okay.
Pots,
okay in California,
but in the neighboring state,
it's not like because a bunch of people
that you and I have never met got
together and wrote down words on a piece
of paper and then call those words a
law.
Writing down words on a piece of paper
and calling you a lot doesn't alter
morality either.
It's perfectly moral for me to smoke pot
or drink alcohol or smoke crack or it's
not.
And the politicians getting together and
writing down words on a piece of paper,
calling it a law doesn't alter morality
in any way whatsoever.
And so this poor young man is going to
die in prison unless he somehow gets an
appeal or it gets out,
um,
for making a website that allowed people
to buy and sell these things that make
them feel happy.
I,
for anybody who's drank some alcohol or
smoke some pot before they do it because
it makes them feel happy.
It makes their,
improves people's lives.
And Yeah,
some people get out of hand and get
addicted and do bad things.
But,
uh,
that's life.
You know,
people die all the time.
Some people eat greasy hamburgers and
get obese and die of a heart attack.
It's their life to do it with.
It's not the politicians lives.
Yeah.
So you mentioned a second ago that you
were a citizen of the United States.
You actually renounce your citizenship.
About what?
About five years ago?
Two thousand and 14.
May Fourth,
I'm sorry,
February fourth.
Uh,
it's one of the crowning achievements of
my life.
I had.
My only regret is that I didn't do it
sooner.
Okay.
So you are a citizen of Japan.
So I,
I'm,
I'm not a citizen of Japan either.
I'm actually a citizen of a wonderful
country in the Caribbean called Saint
Kitts,
which is probably a country nobody's
ever heard of because there's only about
45,000
people in the entire country.
So wait,
first,
why did I think it was Japan?
Is that I've been living in Japan for
over a decade.
Japan's my main home base.
Japan is a wonderful country.
Anybody who hasn't visited there,
you were in for a real treat if you go
and visit Japan at some point.
Yeah.
So,
so what caused this decision a couple of
years back and why?
St?
Kit?
Well,
um,
when I first got out of federal prison,
I felt I had been treated incredibly
unfairly by the United States
government.
For people that are interested in the
details.
We can talk about it or Roger really
shooting maybe real quick.
We should just hit on that.
So why were you in prison?
Yeah,
sure.
So the short summaries,
I read all these economic books and I
got really excited about the power of
economic freedom to make the world a
better place.
And so I thought the best way to tell
more people about the wonderful benefits
of economic freedom was to run for
California state assembly as a
libertarian candidate.
So in the year 2000,
I ran for state assembly as a
libertarian.
I got to have a debate against the
Republican and Democratic candidates at
San Jose State University.
And in that debate I called the ATF and
FBI a bunch of jackbooted thugs and
murderers and reference to all the
children that they burned to death in a
church in Waco,
Texas in I think 1994,
I believe it was.
And uh,
maybe their parents were religious nuts
and really believed in all sorts of
magic skype people in Jesus this and
Jesus that
even if their parents were religious
nuts burning to death,
all the kids doesn't help them.
You murdered a bunch of kids.
So if you're somebody that goes and
burst at the bunch of kids in a church
because their parents are religious
nuts,
you're not a good person.
So I called the ATF and FBI agents,
a bunch of jackbooted thugs and
murderers in reference to what they did
in Waco,
Texas back then.
I still think there are a bunch of
jackbooted thugs and murderers for what
they did there.
And not just that,
there's plenty of examples,
but
it turned out there were some plain
clothed atf agents and the audience,
and at that point I was torn to your 21
years old somewhere in that ballpark and
I had already had some success in
business and they really didn't like the
things that this young man was saying as
they started looking into me and
figuring out,
well,
how can we prosecute this guy?
And so at the time,
uh,
I was telling computer components on
Ebay and I was also selling a product
called a pest control report,
2000 on Ebay,
which is basically a firecracker used by
farmers to scare birds,
other cornfield.
And today that sounds a bit crazy to
sell firecrackers on Ebay.
This was in 1999 or so.
This was back when he had a guns and
ammo section.
You could buy ar,
fifteens and shotguns and ammunition,
and they had a fireworks section and it,
it wasn't a big deal to be selling those
sorts of things,
so I was selling them on Ebay,
uh,
for those that are familiar Kybella
sporting goods catalog,
but they were selling the exact same
product in their catalog.
Anybody could order them,
they'd ship them to you in the mail.
This was before nine slash 11,
so it wasn't a big deal back then.
Uh,
I wound up being the only person in the
entire nation to be prosecuted for
selling those without a permit.
Even while I was in prison to other
companies,
we're still selling the exact same
product without a permit.
Eventually the manufacturing,
the other resellers were all asked to
stop selling them.
None of them went to prison and them had
to pay a fine.
None of them had any problem whatsoever.
I was the only person in the entire
nation to go to prison or have any
problem for selling them.
So I did 10 months in federal prison,
had three months of a federal probation.
The day I was allowed to leave the
country,
I left the country,
I looked into announcing my citizenship
at that time.
Unfortunately it's very expensive to get
citizenship somewhere else and it's
extra difficult if you're a felon in the
United States to get citizenship
somewhere else.
So I looked into it at the time,
so a lot of money,
a lot of work.
Didn't have as much money then.
So I decided to,
I guess it's good enough to just live
outside of the US.
Needed to pick a country.
Wasn't sure where to go.
Um,
I had had one Japanese girlfriend before
in the United States and it was a good
experience.
So,
uh,
I figured there were more to be had in
Japan,
but,
uh,
if I had had a Russian girlfriend,
I would have wound up in Russia for
Brazilian.
It would have been Brazil.
It was just kind of by chance there was
Japan,
but Harry m more than a decade later and
a very settled in and,
you know,
speak fluent Japanese at this point.
I can give your next interview in
Japanese if you'd like.
But why say kitts though?
It ultimately was saying is one of the
few countries in the world where you can
get citizenship very quickly by
investing in real estate.
So I bought some real estate in St
Kitts,
visited the island in person.
Like I love St Kate's St Kitts is a
gorgeous place,
like the low all years,
maybe 72 degrees and the highest,
maybe 80,
85 degrees.
Not very humid,
wonderful weather all year round.
So I've been spending every single
winter there that I think this winter
will be by like fourth or fifth year.
They're like,
uh,
I'm headed there after La.
So it's a great place.
And uh,
you know,
go on a.
If you're looking for a holiday place,
go to St Kitts.
I really recommended it.
And now you're on that board of tourism
there too,
apparently.
I'm happy to come and say hello.
It's a small place in Saint Kitts.
Um,
what now I can obviously understand now
after hearing your story,
which I had read about,
obviously beforehand,
I can understand your frustrations of
course with the government and all sorts
of things and that they singled out one
person who all that.
Um,
what was it like actually that moment
when you would,
I assume you have to sign a couple of
documents and what are you doing?
You slap a guy high five at the end or
like what,
what was that actual moment?
That's a great story too.
So I had to go to the US embassy in
Barbados and uh,
I can't remember the name of the clerk
there,
but if he happens to see the interview,
I thank you for being such a good sport
and having a good sense of humor with
all this.
So I went up to the and you have to have
an interview,
um,
in order to renounce your citizenship.
And one thing that really surprised me
and I didn't know this,
is you're not telling them that you want
to stop being an American.
You're asking for their permission to
stop being an American.
And I asked the guy at the window,
I said,
have you ever seen somebody be denied
the ability to stop being an American?
And said,
Oh yeah,
it happens all the time.
Really,
really was stunning to me.
I would have thought that if you don't
want to be an American anymore,
it should be up to you.
But no,
our masters in Washington DC decide if
they're going to allow you to stop being
an American.
But uh,
this,
this clerk at the window when I came up
and I gave my bundle of paperwork,
there was a fee.
The fee is even higher now.
Now.
The fees,
2000 something dollars.
When I announced I think it was $440.
And he asked me,
he said,
do you want to pay with cash,
credit card or bitcoin?
And I had the same look on my face that
you just did not.
I said what?
I said,
how,
how would you know that I would be
interested in paying in Bitcoin?
He said,
oh,
we know all about you.
We've,
we've googled you.
And I said,
well,
can actually pay him.
Because it was.
No,
I was just kidding.
So,
so basically you had to fill out,
they knew you were coming,
right?
You need an appointment.
Okay,
fine.
So he was just messing with you,
kind of.
He had a good sense of humor and then,
uh,
so you have the initial,
interview and he,
ca he cautions you.
He says,
uh,
he warns you.
He says,
and you know,
I think the draft is the moral
equivalent of kidnapping and slavery and
war mass murder.
I think taxation is theft,
you know,
I have,
I'm a voluntary,
just,
I don't believe in,
you know,
in government.
And he told me,
I said,
I have to caution you,
if you stopped being a US citizen,
you won't be allowed to serve in the
armed forces.
I thought I'm probably okay with that.
I have to warn you that,
uh,
and so I've been a felon for,
you know,
15 years now,
something more than 15 years.
So as a felon you're not even allowed to
vote anyhow.
And I philosophically,
I'm not really interested in voting at
this point.
And even back then,
I wasn't really interested in voting,
but he told me,
he said,
if you renounce your US citizenship,
you won't be allowed to vote,
man.
He was just throwing you all the eggs.
And then another one.
So,
you know,
at the time,
I don't know,
I was 34,
I think he said if you were announced
your US citizenship,
you won't be allowed to collect social
security.
And I'm pretty sure that's not going to
be around by the time I'm old enough to
retire also.
So this was like a real breakup
situation.
They were,
they were pulling out all the stops and
he has his script that he has to cost
me.
And I think there might've been one more
thing,
but all,
all of those were like,
instead of like,
oh my God,
what was I thinking?
It was like,
Hooray,
I can't wait to be free of social
security and all of this stuff.
So,
uh,
and so,
it's,
it's not a decision that people take
lightly either.
It's a big,
big,
big step in life.
But,
uh,
they make you have a one week cooling
off period.
So he cautioned me of all those things
and then I had to hang around for
another week on the island where I don't
know anybody.
Then went back a week later and signed
the paperwork and this and that.
And uh,
I was free.
So that's it.
Yeah.
That's it.
And you did it.
So now you're a felon without US
citizenship.
Yeah.
And so every single time I come into the
country now I get sent to the secondary
inspection and one,
there was another guy a because it on
your.
Well,
no,
you don't have a passport anyway,
but is there something on your passport
get flagged in the US system as you
know,
watch out for this guy.
And so another interesting thing like
anybody who's met me,
I'm a pretty white collar kind of guy,
um,
but since my actual charges dealing
explosives without a license and it's
worth pointing out that the crime isn't
dealing with explosives to crime is
doing it without the license,
without permission slip.
But that's automatically considered to
be a violent felony.
So I,
not only am I a felon,
I'm a violent felon as well.
And so when I,
to have a buddy that would sell
firecrackers out of his basement in
highschool now,
pretty common when we were probably in,
you know,
in the nineties in highschool,
I think so.
Um,
but,
uh,
I get flagged on their computer and
they're like,
oh,
watch out for this case.
They the me to the secondary inspection.
Sometimes they're real uptight about it
and they're watching me.
And then other times they're like,
what do you do?
I said it's sold firecrackers and Ebay.
And they're like,
oh,
you're that guy,
that guy.
But apparently they have some list of
notes about being on their computer and
they have to read all the past notes
about me and then write new notes about
the time that I'm coming into the list
of notes they have to read about me gets
longer every single time I come into the
country.
So it's a bit of a burden guy.
It sounds like an episode of Seinfeld on
crack or something.
Um,
all right.
Well I think,
I think we did a little bit of
everything here.
I wanted to do the one on one stuff,
which I know you've talked about many
times before and I wanted to get some of
your bio if you had to,
just to wrap this whole thing up.
If you had to predict where this is all
going.
Obviously you're very hopeful for all of
this,
but you know,
there is some upside down stuff.
I,
you know,
we didn't even talk about the red.
It's split and you know,
there's some people that are,
you know,
you've got your haters and trolls and
all that.
I'll deal with them.
Don't send them to me.
I'll deal with him.
Fear not.
But if you had to give me like a
prediction of where you see all this
over the next couple years,
what do you think's going to happen?
So a couple of hundred years ago,
if I told you there's going to be a
separation of church and state,
you would think I'm a nutcase and a
heretic and I might get burnt at the
stake for saying such a thing.
Um,
before the invention of Bitcoin,
it would sound crazy to say that there's
going to be a separation of money in
state,
but now that doesn't sound so crazy
anymore and it's starting to happen
right before our eyes.
And I think within another couple of
decades,
all currencies are going to be at,
beyond the control of,
of governments.
People aren't,
aren't going to be using dollars and
euros and yen.
They're going to be using bitcoin cash
and ethereum and Minero and things like
that.
And,
uh,
that's a wonderful,
wonderful thing for,
for all of humankind.
And uh,
just like a separation of church and
state was a great thing for all of human
kind of separation of money in state is
as well.
Yeah.
Well,
I got to tell you,
I thoroughly enjoy this.
I,
you know,
I find I always learn a little something
when I'm doing these,
but I think I learned a lot here and as
I said,
you know,
these are ideas.
The ideas that I try to put into this
business that I built a business here
are the same ideas that I try to talk
about it on the philosophical level and
now we've got to turn these two point
five into into something major,
so let's do it.
You're officially my business manager or
something.
Now my digital cryptocurrency business
manager.
I buy that.
I'll gladly do that and I'll help you
set up a bitcoin cash donation address
on your website and I'm sure people
would love to send you tips and bake on
cash.
There you go.
Awesome.
But it was a pleasure talking to you and
for more on Roger,
you can go to bitcoin.com
or follow him on twitter.
It's at,
it's at Roger K veer.